how hard do you think it is for aliens
to communicate with humans so is this
something you um
think about about this barrier of
communication between biological systems
and something else
how difficult is it to find a common
language
well i think if you're smart enough
or technologically enabled enough it's
relatively straightforward
um
now
whether your concepts
can ever be dumbed down to us
that might be hard
i mean again talking to the ants talking
to the ants i mean on instagram
so
[Laughter]
you want to look good in this picture
let me explain let me explain to you why
yeah
so
that's the essential problem of
you know
perhaps they realize
who it is that they're talking to
and they say we're
rather than muddy the picture we're only
going to give them limited information
yeah right and yeah maybe we could sit
down
like you and i and have a conversation
but then they would make assumptions
the humans would then make assumptions
about us that aren't true
because we're not humans
right so let's stay at arm's length
let's just let them know that
we're here
right and here's a limited amount of of
communication again this this notion
that
if you give somebody everything they'll
get lazy
and you know if if they've been around
as long as they have they've seen every
kind of thing that can go wrong
and so it's it's they know as much as
they might want to step in
that would be a wrong thing
yeah you have to also understand that
the the amount of wisdom they carry
yeah
you know and so it's it's very easy as
well for religions to i don't want i
don't want to get into a whole religious
conversation but you could very easy for
reli you could see how religions
could call them angels or devils or
what have you because
again if you're trying to fit it into a
framework of cultural
understanding um the first thing you
reach for
is god
and so
it
when you when you look at what these
things are and again it with the angels
and the devils
in a similar sort of way
their communication is limited
they just kind of give little
what's the the oracle of delphi they
kind of give these delphic
pronouncements and then it's up to you
to figure out what it is that they
really mean
you